okay so we finally got to see the rings
of the mandarin
in the new shang chi trailer and it's
kind of cool right we're gonna break
this whole thing down here which is
gonna be kind of tough to do because
honestly the trailer didn't really give
us anything that we hadn't seen in the
first one but there were a few big
things that we saw
number one we finally know where emil
blonsky's been right abomination was
like in the great big huge fighting cage
not really sure how he escaped last i
heard last i saw if i remember correctly
and it's been a long time since i saw
the incredible hulk with edward norton i
guess he was just let loose
anyway regardless of the situation
that's where he is now which is kind of
cool to see them actually do something
with emil blonsky by god i never thought
he was going to make his return
the second thing that we got to see is
what looked like finn fang foom now
supposedly the idea of fin fang fume
in chiang chi had been completely
debunked like three weeks ago
so only one of two things is going on
either it was being debunked because
they were lying to us and they just
wanted to build up the hype and
excitement so that when it was revealed
that it was finn fang fume it'd be a
great big huge deal
or that's accident car i'm more inclined
to believe that it's action car just
given the origin of the ten rings and
the mandarin and all that kind of stuff
but it's a giant dragon
fin fang fume is a giant dragon okay so
let's turn to the comments explain for a
second because there's not a whole lot
to break down here i mean it's kind of a
cool trailer
let's give you guys a little bit of
history about the 10 rings the mandarin
what the rings are how all that stuff
works
okay so there was a comic book ron of
iron man that was written by a guy named
matt fraction a
legendary iron man comic book run and i
have it all over comics explained so
make sure you guys check out the
description at the end of this video but
the whole thing behind this is it gave
us a really
more updated and a really really
accurate origin for the mandarin so the
way this worked is that the mandarin was
actually a guy who was born to a
prostitute in an opium den
yeah didn't really come into the world
in the best situation
but ultimately he ended up basically
escaping after his mom died and then he
got caught up in the communist
revolution in china which
ultimately he ended up fleeing china
because he was considered a fugitive now
an invincible iron man issue 522 which
was written by matt fraction we found
out that the mandarin had actually
traveled to a place called the valley of
spirits
where he came across a cave that was
being occupied by axing car
now action car is what you call a
mcluhan that's also the same thing that
finn thing fume is
these are basically extraterrestrial
aliens finn fang boom looks like a giant
dragon he really is in a lot of ways a
giant dragon technically he's a shape
shifter but the form he takes is that of
a giant dragon but axon carr was
basically a mcluhan who left his world
and even his own galaxy to explore the
universe and to see if there was any
other intelligent life there he arrived
on earth and found intelligent life
the problem is the intelligence of the
life on earth led them to kill him
or at least mortally wound him and so
when the mandarin found axon carr
in the cave he killed him and then took
the 10 rings now the 10 rings are
basically these items that were actually
powering the ship in the the original
story but they actually have power of
their own technically they encase the
spirits
of like long dead cosmic warriors and so
a person who possesses the rings
can use the power of the warriors the
idea behind it though is it's very much
like the ring of sauron from lord of the
rings in the sense that when a person is
in possession of the ten rings they have
this constant drive and desire to
actually help those cosmic warriors
return to their normal bodies and that
started to play out to a degree during
matt fraction's run when the mandarin
forced tony stark to build these great
big huge
mech suits that the cosmic warrior
spirits could occupy it didn't quite
work out and i believe that was in the
story called the rings but it didn't
quite work out and so of course you know
the day was more or less saved from the
earth being conquered by
cosmic beings with seemingly unlimited
power
but to break these rings down here's how
they work and here's how these rings
function
so the first ring you have here is one
called the remaker and this basically
allows the mandarin to
alter the molecular structure or the
atomic structure of matter but there are
limitations
it does not allow the mandarin for
example to turn a teacup into
like a pot of gold or something like
that he can't really transmute matter so
he can't turn something into something
else
he can just kind of manipulate the
atomic structure of it this is kind of a
way for marvel to explain
yeah he can use the ring to alter the
atomic structure of matter but he's
never going to be on the same level as
the molotow man owen reese he can't
alter reality on a universal scale
just on a super small scale the second
ring is called
influence and this is basically just a
ring that allows the mandarin to emit
like concussive blast right to literally
just
blast people with huge amounts of energy
now there doesn't really seem to be a
definitive upper limit to the amount of
energy he can use and the energy seems
to be relative to whatever villain
he's facing off against at the time more
often than not marvel's kept it pretty
small
mostly because of the fact that the
mandarin is largely an iron man villain
and so you don't really need the ability
to shatter a world
when you're fighting iron man the third
ring is called spin
and this is one that basically allows
the person who's using it to kind of
emit this vortex to create what is
basically a mini tornado
and they can use this for a couple
different ways one they can encase other
people in it and they can trap them
there
they can throw them off their guard in
the case of iron man he can use it on
him and just make him spin
you can use it to make yourself fly but
it's basically the ability to control
the air around you
and use that for a variety of different
purposes usually it's used with flight
the next one is called nightbringer and
this is actually a ring that's a little
bit wonky here so the whole idea behind
nightbringer is it basically allows the
mandarin to encase a person in what is
more or less living darkness and marvel
comics we call this dark force energy
the dark force dimension is kind of a
weird thing right it's not like the dark
dimension of dormammu
but it's a wholly separate dimension
whereby it's kind of like a ethereal
sort of
substance that actually absorbs light
and so because of that if you encase a
person
in this no light can get in and no light
can get out and they're literally just
wrapped in this this
kind of substance there's no way for
them to escape and so from that point
going forward for however long the
mandarin keeps them encased there
unless a person's able to escape from it
they'll be locked in eternal darkness
they'll never know where they are
like literally they could start walking
in a forward direction and get hit by a
car
it's a weird thing it's cool you don't
really see it all that often
now the funny thing is that this ring
also has a few other caveats to it light
force generations the ability to
basically blind a person with a bright
light
the ability to create magnetic fields
the ability to enhance the gravity
around
individuals so the nightbringer ring is
intriguing in that it's different from a
lot of the other rings because it has a
couple extra caveats that the other
rings simply just don't have
now incandescence is a pretty
straightforward ring this one just
allows him to emit and control
fire not a whole lot to it besides that
now the liar
is my personal favorite ring and this is
the one that allows the mandarin to
manipulate the thoughts of others
but when he uses this he in effect has a
low grade level of what we would call
telepathy throughout marvel comics so
using the liar ring does not put him on
the same scale as like jean grey or
professor x of the x-men there'd be no
way he could overcome them given that
ring but
he is able to use it to create like
mental illusions or to trick people into
believing that an original idea is
actually their own
instead of his it really is just
telepathy in its most pure form now
whenever the mandarin uses the liar ring
one of the things he most commonly does
with it is create mental paralysis and
this does a couple different things
depending on the context and who's
writing the story
either it's straight up paralysis where
the person's mind is completely shut
down and they go into what's effectively
a comatose state or
it keeps the brain from being able to
send messages to the rest of the body
so they are effectively locked inside
their own head again it really depends
on who's writing the story there brian
michael bendis has done it one way
matt fraction is done at another but at
the end of the day it all still pretty
much achieves the same result which is
incapacitating that person using mental
abilities now the last two rings
lightning and zero are a lot like
incandescents they're pretty basic
lightning as you can guess allows the
mandarin to emit and to control
lightning zero allows him to emit and to
control cold now one of the big
differences here with zero and somebody
like iceman bobby drake
is the mandarin's abilities are not on
that same level right iceman bobby drake
is an omega level mutant he has the
ability if he chose to to actually
freeze the core of the earth and kill
life on it the mandarin
doesn't quite have that ability again
his powers are on a much smaller scale
so encasing people in ice making them
incredibly cold freezing the environment
around him that kind of a thing
but again it's all done in a localized
space as opposed to potentially being
done
in a global space but those are the
rings of the mandarin that's basically
how they all work
one of the things that's interesting
about the movie is instead of them being
actual rings that he wears on his
fingers
instead they're bracelets so i don't
know why they don't call it shang chi in
the legends of the tin bracelets
probably because it just doesn't have
the same ring to it right no pun
intended
but it just doesn't quite have the same
kind of you know pizzazz right just
doesn't roll off the tongue as well
which is fine and also if we're looking
at the idea of that dragon which is
hopefully finn fang fume having been the
person that originally wielded the rings
well it would make sense they would have
to be bracelets because that guy's
fingers are probably
huge so he wouldn't have to they would
have to fit on those fingers means those
rings would have to be enormous
but having said that one of the big
things that goes on here and this is
something to kind of keep in mind when
it comes to the movie is we don't
exactly know how those rings
are coming to the mandarin we don't know
if the rings somehow have the caveat of
giving him an extended lifespan
if those rings have been passed down
over the course of generations and the
trailer he says
over the course of my life he doesn't
say over the course of our entire family
history it's just
over the course of my life so we don't
know how far back those go
and if they focus largely on the comics
then it could be one of these things
where the mandarin just stumbled across
the rings in his youth
and has been using them ever since it
may be one of these things where it was
largely given to him
under the pretenses he would use it for
good and then in turn decide to use it
for evil we've seen stuff like that play
out marvel comics all the time
that's how doctor doom stole all the
vibranium and wakanda was by tricking
the panther god baths so this is pretty
common stuff to take place in marvel
comics we see it happen all the time but
again
the marvel cinematic universe kind of
has its own format and its own function
it changes things around a little bit
but
you know the thing about the trailer it
looks like they're obviously keeping a
lot of things hidden right a lot of the
major plot of the movie a lot of the
little easter eggs that we're gonna see
maybe other appearances that are gonna
show up they're keeping a lot of that
stuff contained
this had a lot of recycled footage from
the first trailer
so i'm not too upset about it honestly i
kind of expected that it's only the
second trailer i imagine once we get to
the final trailer the actual
end-all be-all trailer just before the
film's release we'll start getting some
new footage and if we don't
no big deal at least i don't have to
worry about going into the movie and
having it spoiled for me so
with that being said guys let me know
what you think about the trailer down in
the comments section
and we will catch you all later peace